Guys and gals are flirting with each other
everywhere, but NONE OF Y'ALL can tell when
it's actually happening.
What is WRONG with us?!
Howdy hotties, Trace here reporting for DNews.
I'm a flirt, I've been told.
I swear I don't even know I'm doing it!
And apparently, neither does anyone else according
to a new study from University of Kansas published
in Communication Research.
The researchers asked pairs of over one hundred
heterosexual college students to gauge first
impressions during a 10 to 12 minute conversation.
Afterward, each person filled out a questionnaire
and was instructed to indicate if they felt
they'd been flirted with, and if they'd done
any flirting themselves.
*Rawr* Science is hot.
In the end, only 36 percent of the males and
18 percent of the females correctly wrote
they'd been flirted with.
That's everyone.
This is really bad.
And what's worse is, 80 percent of the time
both groups knew when they WEREN'T being flirted
with!
The researchers are showing that we suck at
flirting, or at least at knowing that it's
going on.
But it's not just the people getting flirted
with - the University of Kansas researchers
showed a video of the conversations to over
250 other people for a second study.
You might think you'd spot people's attempts
at flirtation, but no.
Our wingmen and wingwomen are also crap at
flirt-dar.
When women were watching men flirt, they identified
it as flirting 22 percent of the time, and
men and women were a BIT better at picking
up when the ladies were flirting...
Apparently, us dudes are just TOO subtle.
Though that's not been the experience of pretty
much anyone ever.
The researchers found that in fact the lady-flirters
were being more transparent about what they
were doing.
Why do we suck at this simple element of human
attraction?
Should we have evolved to know when another
person wants to practice breeding with us?
Well, the researchers believe it has to do
with the same mechanism as detecting a lie;
which we're also terrible at.
See, the problem is flirting is the subtle
art of body language.
Non-verbal communication is extremely important
for flirtation, which is perhaps why it's
so hard to pick up on a video.
Light touches or squeezes on the arm are extremely
positive, as is eye contact, smiling, laughing,
open body posture (as in the opposite of crossed
arms or legs) and mirroring the other person's
behavior.
Like you both scratch your nose or tousle
your hair.
The BBC writes 55 percent of flirting is done
in this way, while an additional 38 percent
has to do with the tone and speed of your
voice.
Note, this is HOW you're saying it, not WHAT
you're saying -- they've found that's only
about seven percent.
This supports the idea that flirting is driven
not by pick up lines, fancy cars or titles,
but by our non-verbal cues, our tones of voice
and many other subtle factors -- so it's not
surprising to me that people are bad at picking
it out.
The lead research in the Kansas study said
not to assume everyone is flirting with you,
but if you're at a location where flirting
is common, like a social gathering, or a bar,
and you miss the signs, then QUOTE, "that's
on you."
How do you know if someone is flirting with
you?
Do you think you can tell?
Share some flirting tips in the comments.
Be sure you keep them respectful, and thanks
for watching DNews!
If you're into looking deeply into the eyes
of some Earth Science people from NASA/JPL
then tomorrow, June 24 -- you should come
to our hangout!
The links to RSVP are in the description.
30 percent of NASA/JPL is Earth-focused science,
so there's a lot to talk about!
Come join us!